[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire le pouvoir d'achat c'est
l'une des principales préoccupations des
français et l'on peut les comprendre
beaucoup de choses en dépendent des s'il
est facile de mesurer son évolution à
court terme il est beaucoup plus
difficile d'en avoir une vue exacte sur
le temps long nous nous rendons tous
content que les prix de l'énergie sont
en hausse depuis quelques mois que le
tarif de l'électricité vient d'augmenter
de 4 % que les produits alimentaires
sont plus chers nous en concluons que
notre pouvoir d'achat est en baisse mais
qu'en est il à plus longue échéance le
prix de l'essence n'a cessé d'augmenter
depuis la crise du pétrole il ya 50 ans
mais nous coûte t elle plus cher pour
autant et l'électricité le téléphone la
baguette la viande les voitures plus
chères ou moins cher qu'il ya 50 ans
bref notre pouvoir d'achat et ils en
hausse ou en baisse depuis pompidou et
giscard sommes nous plus riches ou moins
riches qu'avant pour en débattre nous
avons invité françois xavier haut niveau
vous êtes l'auteur de la crise de
l'abondance aux édition de
l'observatoire votre point de vue
d'abord est-ce que
tout est plus cher où tout est moins
cher bonsoir faudrait que sur le temps
long c'est assez clair que tout est
moins cher ou pratiquement tout est
moins cher paradoxalement et c'est très
surprenant mais en fait quand vous
regarder dans le détail en effectivement
les prix baissent c'est l'effet du
progrès technique mais notre pouvoir
d'achat sur la durée depuis environ 200
ans depuis le début de la révolution
industrielle augmente de manière un
18/20 débit table donc depuis 200 ans
les prix baissent notre pouvoir d'achat
montrent depuis 50 ans c'est la même
chose depuis 50 ans âge du pétrole
depuis le temps qu'on nous dit qu'on est
en crise et le taux cible depuis le
temps qu'on le dit qu'on est en crise et
c'est encore le cas depuis trois mois
n'ont évidemment il ya l'aspect court
terme effectivement et les tensions sur
beaucoup de choses notamment l'énergie
et des matières premières du transport
de chine mais mais sur la durée sur la
longue durée le progrès technique fait
considérablement baisser les prix et on
vit c'est pas une nouveauté mais on vit
beaucoup beaucoup mieux que y'a que ya
vingt ans et qu'il ya cinquante ans que
ya cent ans oui mais alors pourquoi
est-ce qu'on a l'impression que tout va
être plus en plus balle passée il ya
encore des gels et jaune ça c'est ça
veut dire ça veut pas dire qu'on vit
bien géré on vit mieux mais on nie pas
mais ceux qui agissent pas bien
aujourd'hui j'ai plutôt mieux que ce qui
n'est pas bien il ya soixante dix ans
mais ça va pas dire qu'ils vivent qu'il
est bien encore christopher a beau vous
vous êtes membre du collectif les
économistes atterrés vous enseignez à la
sorbonne et vous publié le 22 février
pour une économie républicaine aux
éditions de boeck supérieur c'est bien
c'est comme ça qu'on dit de bloc
supérieur de bouc tout tout est plus
cher où tout est moins cher de notre
point de vue sur longue période je suis
d'accord avec le diagnostic précédents
ont bien entendu que la grâce aux
progrès techniques mais elles et les
prix y est un opci rien pour là avec une
petite nuance comme sur un poste très
important
qui est le poste du logement ou là où on
observe ces vingt trente dernières
années une très forte hausse notamment
des loyers de la possibilité d'accession
à la propriété voilà mais ce que je
voulais dire c'est que ce qui est
important on se compare jamais quand on
vit on se compare jamais comment on
vivait mon arrière grand mère non on se
compare avec les gens avec lesquels on
vit et je pense que le gros problème il
ya deux gros problème ce point d'achat
bien le sentiment qui est une série de
besoins satisfaits qu'ils pourraient
être satisfaits qu'ils ne le sont pas il
reviendra dans la discussion et la
deuxième chose très importante c'est des
inégalités 20 c'est à dire que
ajuste type de vos points de vue nombre
de citoyens jugent qu'il n'est pas
acceptable que tout en haut de l'échelle
parce qu'en fait le décrochage les
inégalités se sont creusées
en haut de l'échelle et conduit de
l'autriche elle s'est même pas les 10%
c'est celle est important et c'est
surtout parmi les 1% les 0,1 pour cent
convives lors leur niveau de vie
littéralement explosé et ça ça remet en
cause le pacte républicain le fait qu'
on vit dans la même société alors pour
que les baisses que quand on dit que
tout est de moins en moins cher ça
demande quand même quelques explications
c'est pas intuitive c'est pas forcément
le souvenir qu'on en a y compris pour
ceux qui ont vécu en 1970 ce n est pas
cool le prix du litre d'essence c'était
un franc 10 aujourd'hui c'est un euro 80
alors comment expliquer que que les en
dépit du fait que depuis 50 ans
l'essence n'a cessé d'augmenter elle
soit moins cher aujourd'hui c'est une
très bonne question parce
qu'effectivement on a l'impression et
les prix montent effectivement quand ils
sont libérés en europe pourquoi parce
que pour des questions qui sont concrets
de l'argent et donc en fait on pousse
tous les prix vers le haut mais on
pousse aussi les salaires vers le haut
est ce qu'il faut ce dont il faut se
souvenir c'est le niveau du salaire en
1970 ce bien sûr si on se dit un franc
10 en 1970 ces quelques c'est moins de
20 centimes aujourd'hui ça paraît très
très bas mais il faut se souvenir que le
smic en 1970 c'était 3 francs 50 de
leurs trois francs 50 et donc ça veut
dire qu'en 1970 vous achetiez un litre
d'essence un froid 10 avec un smic à
3,50 vous deviez travaillé une vingtaine
de minutes pour acheter un
nouvel et quelque dix minutes
aujourd'hui et 10 minutes aujourd'hui
puisque vous avez un s'miles autour de
10 euros 50 vous avez un litre d'essence
qui a entre 1 70 5 80 90 aujourd'hui
donc c'est effectivement fortement
augmenté mais on reste autour d'une
dizaine de minutes donc ça veut dire que
en fait les choses ans et pour un
smicard et et deux fois quasiment
de deux fois moins cher aujourd'hui
qu'en 1970 malgré l'opep malgré la crise
du pétrole malgré la hausse de la
fiscalité puisque les taxes ont
considérablement augmenté malgré tout ça
vous avez une essence qui est deux fois
moins chère elle permet de rouler plus
parce que les moteurs ont amélioré leur
rendement donc on va encore plus loin
donc en terme de pouvoir le déplacement
à s'améliorer et elle est beaucoup moins
polluante vous avez beaucoup moins de
particules fines et vous avez beaucoup
moins d'effets négatifs les deux
meilleures qualités et tout en étant
deux fois moins cher alors elle est deux
fois moins cher pour un smicard est ce
qu'elle est deux fois moins cher pour
tout le monde a beaucoup augmenté ces
derniers mois là j'ai pourtant j'ai pris
le j'ai pris le tarif d'aujourd'hui hier
ceux qui font leur plein ou écrire c'est
quand même important ils ont senti
passer mais quand dira s'il s'agit de
dire que parce que s'il s'agit dira
qu'il faut faire attention à certains
discours de la déploration qu ils s
entendent que tout est noir qu'il n'y a
plus aucun acquis social que c'était
bien mieux l'avant moi je suis content
ce discours dans la déploration
effectivement je pense que il alors il
exprime quelque chose il exprime le fait
qu' on n'a plus aujourd'hui d'horizon
d'espérance et quand on a plus d'horizon
d'espérance tournoi le passé non
seulement on se tourne vers le passé
mais on a tendance est effectivement à
bananes à ne pas pouvoir affronter la
situation présente on a besoin toujours
de se projeter dans l'avenir et comme on
a pu cet horizon d'espérance joue la
fille copains pendant un siècle et demi
l'horizon d'espérance pour ceux qui qui
modère qui contestait les injustices
sociales c'était socialisme voilà on
était pour l'été compte c'était ça qui
structurait le débat voyez ce que je
veux dire cette page est tournée un
largement avec la chute du mur de berlin
et donc depuis a pu il ya plus il ya
plus cet horizon d'espérance c'est ce
que j'essaie de rebâtir avec l'idée
d'économie républicaine mais comment
dire et donc le le le et donc le
sentiment de déploration un temps
effectivement à l'emporter alors ceci
étant posé après une fois qu'on a dit ça
il faut bien prendre conscience malgré
tout des difficultés qu'ils connaissent
une très grande traîneau on va y revenir
justement ces difficultés mais encore de
trois exemples pour le cas d'une voiture
vous avez fait les calculs aussi une
voiture d'entrée de gamme vous avez pris
la 2 chevaux en 1967
vous dites 2000 360 heures de travail à
l'époque en 1967 aujourd'hui pour une
voiture équivalente c'est plus la deux
chevaux mais même voiture d'entrée de
gamme seulement 1000 heures de travail
aujourd'hui on vient jouer pour un
smicard toujours pour un smicard c'est
effectivement devant ma chère et je
rejoins christophe ramaux sur le fait
qu'il ya une logique aussi de projection
et d'espoir mais il faut effectivement
comprendre qu'on est effectivement dans
une tendance longue d'amélioration du
pouvoir d'achat est effectivement cet
exemple de la voiture est intéressant
aussi parce que aujourd'hui on paye plus
de deux fois moins cher une voiture qui
calme de bien meilleure qualité et à la
deux chevaux des années soixante dix
vous vous souvenez c'est le toit en
toile c'est la direction un peu dur même
très dur j'ai sur toile et celle en
toile pas de ceinture de sécurité un
seul rétroviseurs à gauche comme dans
toutes les voitures à l'époque un moteur
qui est voilà qui était ce qu'il était
donc donc on est une voiture assez
légères d'ailleurs les voitures sont
deux fois plus lourde aujourd'hui parce
qu'elles sont deux fois plus équipés et
donc il ya vous avez aujourd'hui à un
airbag un autoradio évidemment enfin
même système de sont embarqués vous avez
évidemment de rétroviseurs vous avez
tout les systèmes de sécurité direction
assistée donc on est dans une qualité
qui s'est largement amélioré et malgré
ça le coup effectivement est deux fois
moins cher est d'ailleurs le seul
aujourd'hui la plupart des français ont
une voiture au moins une voiture ce qui
n'est pas du tout le corps mais sur nice
donc on a effectivement ce gain de
pouvoir d'achat ce qui n'empêche pas
effectivement ce que les christophe
ramaux c'est la logique de de se
comparer dans relativement à sa propre
époque et donc le fait qu'il ya
effectivement des détentions et des
douleurs quand effectivement quand je
parle de la crise de l'abondance on
parle bien de crise qui sont bien réels
c'est sûr quand on dit on vient d'avoir
une hausse du tarif de l'électricité de
4% et encore c'est bien moindre que ce
qu'on aurait dû avoir en réalité absolue
été amortie par le gouvernement s'est
enfin c'est quand même 4 % et vous avez
raison pour ceux qui payent par rapport
aux et qui s'est tu roule beaucoup d
c'est absolument évident que la hausse
de prix récente évidemment très dur ce
groupe où l'on roule en voiture donc
payer plus cher et ensuite se chauffer
votre identité et 4% c'est plus cher
mais on va voir l'évolution des prix de
l'électricité entre 1950 et 2021 et là
il n'ya pas de doute non plus non oui
c'est ça ça le lumia c'est pas ça c'est
la lumière alors ça c'est même ça même
si c'est une image qui qui qui descend
paléolithique en fait donc c'est le
temps qu'il faut pour avoir une heure de
lumière à l'équivalent de 100 voix que
des ampoules de 100 watts incandescente
et on est passé de 58 heures un quart de
seconde en évoquant 500 militaires donc
ce qui est intéressant donc on est on
est dans cette logique et je vraiment si
c'est sur le fait que c'est on a on a
perdu et c'est ce que dit que ça bravo
une espèce d'aspiration collective il ya
une époque où cette aspiration
collective c'est le progrès évitez de le
dire demain on vivra mieux parce que la
science de nos aïeux est on est on est
on a perdu un peu ça parce qu'il ya eu
deux guerres qui ont été très dures
notamment et qui ont ri qui ont un peu
montré que la science pouvait aussi
servir à faire du mal mais
fondamentalement le progrès technique et
scientifique et est une chance
absolument c'est pas arrêté depuis la
crise du pétrole a arrêté une ville près
du problème accéléré si vous regardez
les taux de croix de d2 décroissance ou
d'amélioration de notre accès à la
lumière elle se sont accélérées au 19ème
siècle on est à 3% de baisse des prix
tous les ans on est à 6 % de baisse
depuis 1900 depuis le passage de du feu
de lampes à huile de la chandelle du
filament de l'éclairage led et on est
effectivement on a une lumière qui est
extrêmement abondante on est beaucoup
plus éclairées la nuit que ce qu'on a pu
être jusqu'à jusqu'à maintenant donc on
a effectivement un accès à cette énergie
lumineuse qui était devenu qui est
devenu très très abondants
mais qui a eu sur le groupe eriad a
fortiori depuis le paléolithique des
graines parti vite et en même temps et
surtout sur 50 ans et en os des
habsbourgs d'accord donc très pas de
souci là-dessus la question que que moi
je me pose c'est est ce que pour autant
partant de là bas il ya plus de raisons
de se révolter
d'accord wham o point de vue c'est de
dire que il ya toujours de bonnes
raisons de se révolter parce que
justement compte tenu de ses gains de
ces gains de productivité de ses progrès
technique de des ressources qu'on aille
bien au pourrait satisfaire de façon
beaucoup plus ample des besoins en
matière de logement on a une crise du
logement il ya un abord de la fondation
de l'abbé pierre qui est paru ce matin
en matière de sauter nous a pas échappé
ses derniers mots ces derniers où ces
deux dernières années que qu'on était à
loos en matière de dépenses de santé à
l'hôpital on était beaucoup trop loin
dans l'austérité donc voilà donc il ya
une cellule manger mieux manger mieux on
a les capacités aujourd'hui dans les
pays développés comme à l'échelle
mondiale on a les capacités de vivre
mieux et bon sang on a un système
économique qui de mon point de vue ne
s'en donne pas les moyens d'où le
sentiment de révolte qui existe et qui
est là qui est de mon point de vue tout
à fait légitimes auxquelles s'ajoutent
mais je pense que c'est lié avec les
deux se tiennent ces inégalités qui sont
ciblés
le point de vue que je soutiens c'est de
dire que au fond dans nos sociétés il ya
un socle d'accord très profond qui n'a
pas toujours existé sur le sur le
politique sur l'idée qu'on doit vivre en
démocratie sur l'idée que le suffrage
universel doit prévaloir plus personne
ne remet ça en cause aujourd'hui il ya
encore quelques temps à l'extrême droite
à l'extrême gauche même ça se discute et
voyez ce que je veux dire
aujourd'hui plus personne ne remet en
cause est la raison pour laquelle on
souffre c'est le sentiment qui a un
domaine l'économie qui échappent à ce
socle d'accord avec des inégalités si
vous êtes dans la sphère du politique
c'est le principe une personne une voix
alors on peut pas être on peut pas
reproduire cette cette logique d'égalité
dans l'économie mais ça serait
l'égalitarisme n'aurait pas de sens et
en a très bien pour récompenser l'effort
ceux qui travaillent plus doit être le
biais mais entretenir ce à dire qu'on va
pas reproduire un système d'égalité
absolue et ses inégalités complètement
abyssal
carlos ghosn qui à l'épreuve pour ne
citer que lui ne s'est pas avérée d'un
apport fondamental pour son entreprise
si je ne m'abuse il gagnait le salaire
moyen de 2 seul employé dès le délai
premiers jours du mois de janvier voyez
ce que je veux dire c'est pas acceptable
c'est pas que ça parce que ça détruit
les collectifs ça détruit les collectifs
ça détruit l'entreprise ne le change du
travail et sedrun et donc je pense que
je pense que c'est ça hein le les soucis
à la hanche et j'aurai une autre
question c'est est ce qu'on ne
s'illusionne pas sur la gravité des
inégalités je parle des inégalités à
l'intérieur d'un pays parce que les
inégalités entre les pays ont tendance à
se tasser en général tout le monde est
un peu d'accord même si entre la france
et haïti y est considérable un fossé
considérable mais c'est fossé entre les
pays riches et les pays pauvres a
tendance à se réduire en revanche à
l'intérieur des pays les scouts et les
inégalités ont tendance à se creuser et
cela depuis les années 80 alors qu'elle
s'était beaucoup réduite tout à fait du
temps de l'union soviétique offrant un
compte y avait de la concurrence est
rude à providence états est fait pour
vidange et d'un concurrent mais est-ce
comme si les jeunes c'est qu'on prend à
chaque fois l'idée on prend les dix
milliardaire français ont dit vous vous
rendez compte c'est dingue outre le fait
que les écarts entre nous et les
milliards de francs sont bien moindres
que ce qu'ils étaient sous l'ancien
régime ou même au 19e siècle où il
fallait voir comment vivent les riches
il vivait un peu mieux que les
milliardaires d'aujourd'hui franchement
ils vivent comme des ploucs par rapport
aux milliardaires enfin autre est très
riche du 19e siècle il avait 60
domestique il vivait dans tous dans des
châteaux pas des châteaux des hôtels
particuliers aujourd'hui il n'y a pas
une telle différence vous trouvez vous
je ne fréquente pas donc je n'étais pas
les informations vous
que vous sous-estimez même pense que
vous sous estime grandement le train de
vie a annoncé ils ont des milliards on a
évidemment gloser là sur l'augmentation
ils ont gagné 400 milliards c'est oxfam
comme d'habitude 400 milliards pendant
la crise de kobe ils ont perdu 100
milliards là il ya deux belges crash
boursier ils ont perdu semblait bien ça
c'est celle des milliards qui n'existe
pas s'acheter tout serait parti avec un
discours parfois de critiques sur la
demande il ya un discours parfois
critique sur la bourse qui en fait
conforte les illusions de la bourse vous
avez un bout de papier qui s'appelle une
action il vaut sans talent jour il vaut
301 boilard hier il a même changé le
site tout le monde essaie de réaliser sa
plus value vous avez raison tout ce
qu'on appelle un crack est donc en fait
c'était une plus-value théorie la main
ton pardon des revenus les revenus saas
et des espèces sonnantes et trébuchantes
d'accord alors sans matière de revenus
les 1% de salariés les mieux payés ça
fait son choix sont 3000 un salarié ils
gagnent au moins au moins au minimum
huit mille 700 euros c'est bien c'est
pas énorme et ça les 0 1% d'accord donc
ça fait seize mille salariés ne me
suivez ils sont à au moins au minimum 22
mille euros le top 1000 bébés attendait
cela depuis un saut et se voit finir le
top 1000 soit 4 9 89 milles ça c'est pas
que ces tables des 89 10 euros par
bribes de salariés là si vous prenez je
n'ai pas que c'est assumé les revenus
c'est pas ce pack je m'appelle capital
si vous prenez les ce qui touche 22000
vous savez bien qu'à la fin quand ils
ont payé leurs impôts caisses qu'ils
aillent en plus patent c'est à la source
il leur reste dix mille
si vous restez mobiles à peu près quand
vous êtes à 22000 il vous reste pour la
ville après comme je parle pour cela
mais comment dire là je parle non plus
de sa de niveau de vie d'accord c'est
pas le
salaire il ya la redistribution mais le
problème kumar vous avez raison de bien
longtemps il ya la fiscalité mais ne
faut pas non plus sous-estimer cet
encours au à quel point pour une frange
extrêmement limité dans votre vaisseau
et ça ça déchire le tissu social si vous
essayez de me faire dire ils sont venus
rejoindre que c'est pas en leur prenant
leurs chaises qu'on va résoudre tous les
problèmes que je suis la cantine ça ne
suffit absolument pas mais c'est un
préalable c'est un préalable pour
refaire société parce que c'est plus
riches mais je parle pas de ceux qui
sont à 10% 1 action à 22000 mais ce
qu'ils sont on sait que ceux qui sont à
100 milles sont ils ont des capacités
d'évasion fiscale qui sont absolument
effroyable et qu'il faut pas
sous-estimer dommage mais je me mêle
trop de la gueule du débat que vous
aviez en fait je rejoins tout à coup sûr
à 100 pour le sujet et notamment jeu
c'est absolument clair que
laisser ses gains de pouvoir d'achat ont
pas été réparties de façon égalitaire ce
qui à la limite pour être expliqué en
disant ben tiens si tu travailles plus
tu gagnes plus ça pourquoi pas et même
de façon juste il ya une vraie injustice
au delà même de l'inégalité dans dans la
répartition de aujourd'hui des revenus
du patrimoine qui est aussi lié que je
décris dans mon livre c'est l'une des
crises qui est l'abondance mais qui est
aussi lié à plusieurs choses dont le
fait que la plupart des revenus sont pas
tous ont de moins en moins lié à la
quantité trike vous fournissez mais à la
proximité vous avez du capital plus vous
êtes près d'un univers où débit capital
plus effectivement les revenus sont
élevés il ya un autre sujet qui sur la
façon de créer de la monnaie qui est
très très inégalitaire et qui est qu'on
a vu d'ailleurs pour la crise du comité
qui a une tendance à accentuer les
inégalités pour le coup de patrimoine
parce qu'il favorise ceux qui ont déjà
dû capital soit sous forme d'immobilier
ça soit c'est que les actions parce que
vous créez de l'argent par la dette
aujourd'hui et donc la dette vous leur
fournissez vers des gens qui peuvent
emprunter les gens qui peut emprunter
ces gens qui ont déjà de l'argent et
donc plus vous avez de l'argent plus
pour emprunter et en fait comme vous
continuez à créer de la dette en
permanence vous allez
réévalué en permanence les patrimoines
donc le
l'immobilier et les actions et donc vous
allez en fait fléché c'est pas du tout
mon père je ne sais pas un complot de la
banque centrale pour dire au revoir mais
qui de fait vous avez un creusement
d'égalité moi je jeu on a on a on a
souligné que les inégalités avaient
baissé considérablement au cours du 20e
siècle jusque dans les années 70 celle
ont redémarré à l'eau soit par tergnier
sont de 10 il ya différentes
interprétations de ça moi je
l'interprète très clairement avec le
fait qu' on ait eu un changement complet
de régime monétaire en 1966 on en sait
des corps et de l'état loi en 1071 et
des accords de bretton à la fin de
l'époque john wood c'est devenu les
changes flottants 73 et à partir de ce
moment là on a créé l'argent par la
dette c'est qu'elle crée deux phénomènes
d'abord l'endettement permanents de
l'état qu'on connaît depuis on a un
budget positif de puissantes 15 mais
c'est aussi lié au fait qu' il y avait
besoin de s'endetter pour rééquilibre
pour équilibrer le l'économie en fait la
dette a été créé en fait à cesser
répondu en marche à ce moment là et il
ya eu aussi un creusement des inégalités
qui a des baraquements et je pense qu'on
est vraiment si on travaille pas sur la
question de la façon dont on crée
l'argent on n'arrivera pas à résoudre à
résoudre le le sujet c'est là où je suis
peut-être en divergence avec christophe
travaux sur le gers est d'accord sur le
diagnostic sur le fait que le linge
disent qu'il ya des unités qui sont
creusés je pense que l'idée c'est moins
de traiter les conséquences c'est-à-dire
dès qu'un creusement à la fin par
l'impôt c'est plus crues étaient à la
source en dix ans la façon dont on crée
de la monnaie au départ et en ce qui
concerne le logement justement parce que
quand vous nous invite tous les prix
baissent vous mettez à bémol aussi au
logement là il y avait une christophe
prat ball alors je suis un dieu tout à
l'heure je vais pas dire qu'ils
augmentent sur la durée ils baissent
aussi beaucoup moins dire que du coup la
part du logement dans le dans le dans le
budget familial augmente parce que leur
prix baisse mans pourquoi est ce qu'ils
baissent moment parce que c'est pas un
produit technologique logement recense
ou une fois que vous avez fait un
logement mais ils bougent pas dans les
années qui viennent si vous vous achetez
une voiture la voiture deux générations
après moins cher et c'est deux
générations d'après moins cher donc vous
avez une espèce de fruits de
consommation et la technologie fait que
ce produit consommation changent tous
les ans et baissent tous les ans soit
vous avez construit un bâtiment voulait
construit une fois et donc donc c'est un
actif il occupe un espace et vous pouvez
pas le dupliquer c'est à dire que si
vous avez un bâtiment un endroit donné
vous pouvez pas
en faire x 10 watts donc vous avez une
vraie rareté dans le logement qui
explique pourquoi est-ce que ce le prix
baissent moins sur le logement je
voudrais quand même rappeler quelques
quelques chiffres on avait par personne
en france dans les années sioniste 23
mètres carrés on a aujourd'hui 40 on a
beaucoup plus de place qu'à l'époque la
qualité des logements s'est
considérablement la durée avec le dieu
en spray la hauteur les bêtes vêtements
les logements baissent ils ont perdu 40
cm je crois alors à français au même
moment à langogne gagner car je ne sais
vous allez vous me l'apprenez alors que
les français ont 700 trimestre à peu
près plus mais en terme de surface vous
avez quand même plus d espace pour vivre
en termes de qualité de logements
absolument comparable en termes de
sanitaires de cuisine d'accès d'eau
courante star à 2 d'isolation des
bâtiments de l'empreinte énergétique des
bâtiments on s'est considérablement
améliorée sans aucun doute on est donc
sur des bâtiments plutôt plus grand et
donc donc la qualité de vie et le
pouvoir d'achat locatif s'est améliorée
ce qui s'est passé c'est que comme les
autres prix baisser on a plus investi
dans son engagement et donc
effectivement on dépense plus
aujourd'hui % logement dans son budget
général mais on a aussi un peu plus de
qualité de logements pour ça après ça
n'empêche pas ce que disait christophe
travaux c'est à dire que vous avez un
problème qui est un peu différent qui
est que l'accès à la propriété est
devenu très compliqué plus tôt dans les
10 15 dernières années jusqu'à jusqu'à
depuis sa jeunesse a plutôt baissé
jusqu'au début des années 2000 et là ça
s'est stabilisé depuis une quinzaine
d'années parce qu'effectivement les prix
du logement ont considérablement
augmenté en même temps les taux
d'intérêt ont baissé les deux sont
corrélés un plus les taux d'intérêt
baissent plus les prix de logements
augmente parce que quelque part
finalement ce que vous gagnez un côté
vous le perdez de l'autre en fête est
donc finalement les forts l'effort est à
peu près le même pour acquérir un
logement simplement effectivement vous
avez besoin de pouvoir vous endetter
pour ak rangement et donc effectivement
s'attend à flécher les logements verts
des personnes plus aisées et par
ailleurs vous avez aussi les effets de
2,2 de déséquilibre aussi se dire que
les logements en centre-ville à paris là
pour le coup ils ont clairement augmenté
ils sont devenus beaucoup plus c'est ce
qu'on appelle gentryfication le fait que
effectivement les personnes modestes qui
vit dans paris ont dû se déplacer en
banlieue dont elles ont plus d espace
mais c'est pas de l'espace de
centre-ville cet espace plus plus plus
en périphérie donc il ya quand même eu
des mutations sociales très fortes qui
ont été liés au logement qui ont fait
des grandes distances mais dire que dire
que le pouvoir d'achat de logements a
baissé je trouve que c'est un peu
simplificateur par rapport à par rapport
à ce qui s'est passé c'est à dire que là
il ya plus de surface ça s'organiser
différemment
mais c'est un peu plus compliqué que ça
en fait logement schl aux logements je
suis d'accord sur fait que les commandes
et ria il ya deux parts dans la hausse
du prix des logements il ya une part
d'améliorations la qualité vous savez
moi je n'ai grandi dans la cité u riga
garine à ivry sur seine qui vient d'être
détruite et avenches d'une maman était
concierge et donc je lui fais dans une
loge dans le 16e arrondissement certes
enfin c'est une loge mais très peu d
espace quand on est arrivé si théorie à
green je vous assure que c'est un
progrès considérable d'accords parce
qu'il y avait il y avait il y avait nos
courante et des toilettes à l'intérieur
et c'est très bien ceci étant posé ce
qui s'est passé là c'est et je rejoins
sur les 20 dernières années on a eu
comment dire on a une vision et une
spéculation immobilière où est alors sur
les cinq dernières années ça c'est la
page la plus sombre du bilan de
maquereaux on a une cordiale il a une
chute des constructions notamment dans
le conte sociable et de façon générale
et donc résultat des courses on n'a pas
assez de logements on a cette
spéculation immobilière et donc les
loyers ont très fortement augmenté ce
n'est pas le cas dans tous les pays
c'est pas plus c'est beaucoup moins le
cas dans des pays comme l'allemagne par
pour plein de raisons y compris
démographique
les pays bas où ils ont beaucoup plus de
logement social que chez nous pour la
population nous il ya aussi les
logements vides on les estime peut-être
trois millions de logements oui bin oui
à transit mais paraît ben oui mais pour
une part parce qu'elle peut faire
inviter très différentes mais ça renvoie
aussi à la spéculation mais pour revenir
peut-être sur le débat si vous permettez
sur le lac estion inégalités moi
j'insiste beaucoup sur le fait que
contrairement à ce qu'on a en tête
j'aime bien réelles contre les idées
reçues c'est pas simplement taxant les
riches qu'on va réduire les inégalités
en fait dans tous les pays du monde
la réduction des inégalités elle s'opère
d'abord par la dépense publique et non
pas par l'impôt
je vais pas vous abreuve de chiffres
mais si on prend le revenu primaire
entre les 10% les plus pauvres et les 10
% les plus riches et des plus riches par
nos on est à les revenus primaires c'est
les revenus d'activité les revenus du
capital on est à 24 24 et 26 % les plus
riches qui a eu 24 fois plus avec
l'impôt on passe à 18
avec les prestations on sociales en
espèces les retraites les allocations
chômage les allocations familiales ça et
avec la consommation de services publics
parce qu'on l'intègre au sein revenus
des ménages la tambouille statistique
qui permet de faire cette chose
remarquable et dont on fait ça dans tous
les pays du monde mais en particulier en
france eh bien on arrive cela combien 6
ou 7 3 3 on en décompte syrienne
réduction absolument considérable des
inégalités qui passe par la dépense qui
passe par la dépense et alors ça veut
pas dire alors je pense que ça ne
devrait plus passer par l'impôt vous
lire on a réduit la progressivité de la
peau on a fait des cadeaux fiscaux
absolument exorbitant ou à la fois aux
entreprises et aux plus riches et
généralement ça va ça va de pair on a
continué malheureusement dans ce dernier
quinquennat mais insistons sur ce poste
qui est le fait que c'est par là c'est
par la dépense est valable pour le
logement pour le logement ce qu'on peut
regretter dans le dernier quinquennat
c'est qu'on ait la baisse des apn on la
prie on appris dans la trésorerie d'eads
et des organismes des anguilles des
bailleurs sociaux et donc ça ça a
conduit à quoi à la fois aux lapins ont
la part belle au rize et les apps et
avant hier par plein de dispositifs on
appris de l'ordre de 10 15 milliards sur
l'aide sociale un logement d'un
quinquennat sur le quinquennat incomplet
et résultat des courses ça aboutisse est
l'une des l'un des éléments qui
expliquent la chute de la construction
de logement social ont fait une pause on
se retrouve juste après on continue ce
débat
[Musique]
2 vous êtes médecin vous rentrez au raid
en 2007 c'était une évidence pour vous
c'est pas un choix facile vous fait le
lien entre la hiérarchie qui n'est pas
médical et les différents médecins c'est
une rencontre entre des intuitions et
puis tout votre bagage technique
bagages humains pour faire face à ces à
ce type de situation pourquoi est-ce que
vous avez choisi d'écrire sur cette
expérience c'est important après le 13
novembre j'ai entendu et lu un peu tout
et n'importe quoi une le médecin sont
son rôle c'est d'arriver à aborder des
sujets difficiles grave la mort mais il
sans cacher la vérité
[Musique]
l'afrique la nouvelle crypte hollande on
a l'impression d'assister un phénomène
de mode qui est amenée à durer
véritablement sur le continent nous
sommes juste entré dans une nouvelle ère
du système financier et vit la
population africaine c'est un milliard
d'habitants
c'est ça à la valeur de nos crypto
monnaie
notre objectif c'est d'avoir de plus en
plus de partenaires qui acceptent notre
crypto comme moyen de paiement qu'en ce
qu'a choisi lusinchi que l'argent
liquide perd de la valeur beaucoup de
pays en afrique ont interdit la crypto
est ce que vous répondez à cela une
canette on ne peut pas dire on va
interdire la crypto d'autant qu'il ya
internet il y aura des trucs
[Musique]
on reprend notre débat sur le pouvoir
d'achat avec françois-xavier olivo
l'auteur de la crise de l'abondance et
avec christophe ramaux qui publie qui
publiera plus exactement dans quelques
jours pour une économie républicaine
alors justement restons sur on est dans
une période un peu particulière on nous
parle du retour de l'inflation
on l'a vu et c'est ce dont on parle
depuis tout à l'heure les prix ont beau
augmenter ça n'est pas forcément plus
cher qu'avant ça peut même être moins
cher d'après vous loue toujours
pratiquement toujours nous dire
christophe ramaux aussi en tout cas
quand on regarde sur le long terme mais
alors il ya le les spirales
inflationnistes
à savoir que les prix morts augmente
depuis quelques mois là depuis trois
mois sur tous les prix augmentent là
tout à coup c'est plus cher mais ont
fait augmenter les salaires et c'est ce
que demandaient les les manifestants il
ya quinze jours augmentation des
salaires pour répondre au pouvoir
d'achat on a connu ça dans les années 70
les prix augmentaient on augmentait les
salaires de ce fait qu'on avait augmenté
les salaires les prix augmentaient
encore un peu plus à la foire pour payer
les employés et parce qu'il y avait plus
d'argent sur la table et c'est une
spirale inflationniste c'est dans une
des raisons pour laquelle on a fait
l'euro tel qu'on l'a fait d'ailleurs
c'était pour lutter contre ça oui alors
ça j'y crois pas trop en fait ni enfin
ça va arriver maintenant non je vais
vous expliquer par en tout cas c'est
chacun sa propre hypothèse le l'avenir
est difficile à prévoir mais mais mais
en tout cas ce que vous décrivez comme
l'espère un spécialiste des années 80
d'abord il y avait 40 derrière
causes racines qui était la création
monétaire encore une fois on a créé
entre 9 et 13 % d'argent tous les ans
dans les années 70-80 donc c'est ça
aussi qui faisait monter à la fois les
prix et les salaires donc c'était pas
forcément une spirale qui s'auto
alimenter mais simplement des prix qui
montent et en parallèle sachant que on
continue en dépit du fait que là on va
ré remonter les taux d'intérêt mais on
continue d'injecter
on en crée moins qu'à l'époque figurez
vous oui on en a créé 20 pendant 20 % de
d'euros en deux ans pour la crise qu
vide c'était à peu près ce qu'on crée
tous les ans en temps normal dans les
années sony c'est 80 dont on a oublié
qu'on avait eu en fait une création
monétaire en fait ce qui se passe donc
on a vu une base de données qui était
beaucoup plus faible et en fait on en
crée beaucoup plus haut relatif donc de
recettes selon la création monétaire
était très très fort tant dans les
années 80 plus qu'aujourd'hui en tout
cas plus que très rarement traduits
prestement plus tôt que dans les années
2010 et même plus qu'actuellement donc
donc donc bon non on a aujourd'hui
clairement un
juste pour les années 80 si vous avez
une spirale inflationniste qui était
aussi dû au fait qu'ils avaient des prix
qui étaient indexés enfin des salaires
qui est indexation des prix et vous
aviez aussi un pouvoir de négociation
des syndicats qui étaient présents plus
fort qu'aujourd'hui aujourd'hui c'est
les syndicats ont plutôt perdu lors
d'une opposition peut le regretter ou
pas mais en tout cas ils ont beaucoup
moins de poids aujourd'hui vous avez une
économie qui est aussi beaucoup plus
désintermédiés donc on dit aussi que les
salaires ont beaucoup moins comme a
augmenté depuis sa tombe ont délaissé
leurs books monte et d'ailleurs les
salaires en 2000 en 2020 ont assez peu
augmenté en réalité donc enfin aux etats
unis ils ont beaucoup augmenté mon en
europe ils ont peu augmenté donc je
crois pas tellement ce démarrage de
spirale inflationniste moi je crois
enfin pour vous dire ce que je pense je
pense qu'en fait on va vers une poussée
assez forte des prix qui est liée à un
redémarrage un choc absolument
incroyable qu'on a subi vers le choc que
l'économie a subi en 2001 en 2021 avec
la crise qu'on vide où on a quand même
fermé pendant plusieurs semaines
plusieurs mois tout l'appareil productif
mondiale c'est un choc absolument nous
ils virent c'est miraculeux enfin c'est
extraordinaire qu'on soit retourné à peu
près à un niveau d'activité d'il ya deux
ans après un tel choc c'est déjà
incroyable
donc c'est normal que vous ayez espèces
dont deux chocs qui fait que ben on
ajuste les capacités de production en
termes d'énergie en termes de matières
premières en termes de transport
maritime et que vous ayez une espèce
d'onde de choc qui se diffuse sur un an
un an et demi peut-être deux ans dans
l'économie qui va effectivement aboutir
qui est en train d'aboutir à une
inflation qui est à une hausse de prix
qui est assez forte mais
fondamentalement les les moteurs de
cette baisse de prix le moteur de la
technologie ils ont pas ralenti et au
contraire ils ont même accéléré on a
accéléré sur le plan technologique
pendant la crise du communal a accéléré
son plan médical on aller beaucoup plus
vite sur la sur la production de vaccins
que ce qu'on faisait avant on a accéléré
sur la nuit risation des entreprises sur
le digital elles ont gagné pour le mans
cinq ans et ça c'est un facteur de
baisse de prix aussi ces facteurs
déflationnistes vous allez baisser les
loyers vous avez 20 des surfaces d'être
des coûts de transport vous allez bcd
des coûts dans les entreprises et donc
en fait le fond de mon déflationniste
structurelle de l'économie il est
toujours là et donc vous allez compenser
aujourd'hui par une très forte hausse
des matières premières mais les matières
premières concerne en deçà des 100 après
la dernière hausse des matières
premières qu'on a eue c'était entre 2012
et 2014 le pétrole était monté de façon
très élevé il est retourné ensuite et on
est rentré en inflation négative en
début de déflation en 2016 je pense que
ça se sait qui c'est ça qui va se passer
aujourd'hui donc je ne crois pas du tout
retour dans la façon je suis c'est pas
tout à fait le consensus de marché en
suisse à fait conscient mais on n'est
pas obligé décor est le marché je pense
qu'au contraire on rentrera dans une
période de très basses inflation
peut-être à horizon 12 18 mois je sais
pas très bien c'est qu'il faut le temps
que cette hausse absorbe mais quand elle
va redescendre il va se cumuler avec
cette baisse cette déflation
structurelles dont moi je vois plutôt
une logique de baisse de prix à
l'horizon 2023 2024
elle s'offre à nos matière d'inflation
il ya deux explications possibles chez
les économistes il ya une première
explication qui est défendu par les
libéraux qui consiste à dire acial
l'inflation c'est parce que la banque
centrale avec l'état derrière a créé
trop de monnaie donc ses origines pas
très bien il est une autre explication
qui est plutôt keynésienne dont je suis
qui consiste à dire
l'inflation les deux rien n'est pas
d'origine monétaire les origines réelles
elle est liée aux coûts de production et
donc je vais vous rejoindre sur le
diagnostic mais pas sur l'explication
aujourd'hui aux vidéos où vit depuis 40
ans aux particuliers en europe parce qu
aux etats unis a eu des inflexions vous
ne vous a pas échappé que joe biden a
mené et a vendu 8 rome quelque part à
mener les politiques de relance
colossal par rapport à ce qu'on fermera
enfin attardons nous sur l'europe et sur
la france on a en france et en europe on
a le néolibéralisme néolibéralisme c'est
quoi c'est notamment donc la finance
libéralisée qui a creusé les inégalités
le libre-échange l'austérité salariale
et ça ça plombe sont les salaires ça
comprime les salaires il ya la menace
permanente aux délocalisations il ya le
chômage comme dit le chômage au delà du
taux de chômage officiel nous on pourra
demain ce qui existe partout en europe
et dans ces situations c'est
historiquement que dans la situation ce
que marx l'armée de réserve quand
l'armée de réserve le chômage le
sous-emploi et tv les travailleurs sont
pas en position de force pour demander
des hausses de salaires et donc il n'y a
pas cette spirale que vous évoquiez prix
salaires qui se met en branle tout
simplement parce que les travailleurs
sont pas en position de force et alors
la question qui se pose c'est pourqui en
charge d'intérêt général c'est à dire le
gouvernement qu'est ce qu'on fait dans
cette situation mon point de vue c'est
de dire il faut remettre aux causes de
néolibéralisme libre-échange la finance
libéralisée la contre-révolution fiscal
mais aussi parce qu'il ya quand même un
choc d'inflation même s'il n'est pas
appelé à durer je suis d'accord mais
quand même à ce choc d'inflation que les
salariés prennent en pleine figure et
l'a2 mon point de vue mais on y
reviendra peut-être dans la discussion
c'est d'avoir vu la bonne solution c'est
pas de bricoler des petites choses comme
la prime inflation extra c'est de
revenir à une logique où effectivement
où devrait être d'origine logique
d'indexation des salaires et des
prestations sociales sur l'inflation de
match on à maintenir le pouvoir d'achat
pourquoi maintenir le point d'achat
parce que le gouvernement se gargarise
qu'en 2021 activités through a repris
très bien heureusement on était mais on
avait des sondés lui marche non à
remonter cette arme est parvenue pour
moi écrire mais c'est très bien mais
quand l'activité reprend quand la
production reprend ben ça veut dire que
les revenus augmentent leur revenu
global celle de je me suis toujours un
ardent défenseur du pib de cet
indicateur tant honnie par certains
parce que on calcule de trois façons
différentes on arrive alors près aux
mêmes chiffres production revenue puis
là depuis un bien piana demande si mme
pib augmente ça veut dire que les
revenus globaux augmente même montant
exactement il faut que les salariés en
bénéficient a pas de réseau qui
bénéficient pas de ces hausses de alors
jeudi des salariés après je suis pour
parce que je veux bien parce que j'ai
tout à l'heure quand j'ai dit qu'on
allait passer à 3 c sur 10 % 10 % si on
prenait 1% les car il n'est pas à 3
frédéric taddéi il reste colossal il ya
de la marge pour réduire les inégalités
quand même mais vous ne m'enlèverez pas
de l'esprit toutefois qu' il ya quand
même un mystère pour pour moi savoir que
si effectivement tout le monde a profité
des gains de productivité des progrès
technologiques
on fait que les prix ont baissé
tendanciellement depuis 200 ans mais
surtout depuis les 50 dernières années
il ya encore des gens j'en fais partie
qui ont connu les tarifs qu'on ne
condamnait tout à l'heure en ce qui
concerne l'essence l'électricité etc et
qui moi compris ont l'impression que
c'était moins cher avant si ça n'est pas
moins cher et si je n'arrive pas à
comprendre si effectivement tout le
monde a gagné en pouvoir d'achat
pourquoi on est si inquiet mais pourquoi
on est surtout on a un tel ressenti on a
tous l'impression d'être plus pauvres
qu'avant vous allez bien c'est pas
seulement parce que au même moment il ya
cinq milliardaire qui me sont beaucoup
plus riches c'est pas ça qui fait qu'on
se sent plus pauvres qu'avant on s'en
fout des cinq milliardaire a des limites
qu'est ce qui fait qu'on se sent plus
pauvres en dépit du fait que
objectivement quand on calcule on est
plus riche mais parce que effectivement
je pense que c'est moins les
milliardaires que le que le voisin en
fait c'est assez amusant parce que quand
vous demandez à des gens à quel niveau
de revenu il serait heureux c'est une
question qui a été posée et la réponse
est assez étonnante parce qu'elle dépend
du niveau de revenu actuel les gens
disent en général à peu près à deux fois
que je gagne ce que je gagne je serai
heureux quel que soit le salaire de
départ est donc en fait c'est un peu la
réponse à votre question c'est qu'on se
quelque part il a voulu christophe
ramaux 1,8 à fait raison on se compare
pas du tout avec avant on oublie que
avant il fallait économiser pour acheter
un 33 tours alors qu'aujourd'hui on a un
abonnement 10 heures qui est qui et qui
est bien mieux on oublie qu avant il
fallait économiser pour le cinéma on
oublie tout ça mais effectivement on se
compare avec des gens qu'on connaît
effectivement bas il ya toujours
quelqu'un qui a un meilleur modèle
d'iphone qui est un meilleur goût de
téléphone qui a une voiture et le toit
que ça augmente et
c'est de façon incroyable le téléphone
l'abonnement téléphonique en dans les
années dans les années 80 c'était 45
francs c'est à peu près l'équivalent
d'une cinquantaine d'euros aujourd'hui
ou 40 heures aujourd'hui mais attendez
c'est pas l'abonnement comme on l'a lu
c'est le câble en cuivre et le thé le
combiné qui arrive chez vous il y avait
zéro communication et que ça ensuite
vous payez chaque communication vous
payez chaque belle époque on avait un
téléphone par famille maintenant il
m'évoque pour toute la famille grâce à
un téléphone par chaque membre
mais même ça c'est moins cher même le
téléphone individuel aujourd'hui pour
toute la famille revient moins cher que
le téléphone en bakélite qu'on avait
avec avec le l'euro qui tournait enfin
sur les télécommunications enfin vous
jouez au jeu vidéo aujourd'hui avec avec
des gens qui sont en australie un appel
téléphonique quand christophe au camp
nou 3 d'ailleurs appelions en australie
quand elles avaient ou ont servi dans la
plaie je sais pas même pas australie
outre-mer ou à l'étranger c'était des
piles de pièces qu'on mettait dans la
cabine téléphonique agir c'est s était
c'était un investissement appeler à
l'étranger cet investissement
aujourd'hui c'est en fin de compte m 2
le pouvoir d'achat en termes de
communications a explosé et simplement
le sujet c'est que vous avez toujours
des vous pouvez toujours pas de preuves
de fin de mois c'est pas pour ça vous
n'avez pas trois de nos fins de mois
c'est peut-être peut-être que vous avez
un projet de fin de mois aujourd'hui
dans un logement qui a 40 cas où avec 44
49 carrés par personne alors que vous en
ayez 23 naissante vous avez une voiture
alors que vous n'aviez pas peut-être
vous avez une télévision alors que vous
n'aviez pas de télévision même noir et
blanc est satisfait de ma course
pourquoi on a l'impression qu'on est
plus pauvres c'est parce qu'on a une
capacité d'oubli quelle incroyable en
fait on oublie ça en fait mais c'est
vrai que et chaque fois qu'on le conte
locon qu'on en parle comme ça en disant
mais quand je discute avec des amis qui
ont cure mandat j'ai alors dit mais à
souviens toi quand tu avais vingt ans le
téléphone souviens toi le disent qu'ils
disaient ah mais oui tu as raison en
fait et en fait on oublie mais mais mais
moi on s'habitue beaucoup en fait à la
boa tout ce qu'on peut vous fournir le
le le le confort parfois aussi ça amène
des problèmes d'hier on mange beaucoup
on a beaucoup plus de nourriture que ce
qu'on avait avant mais ça te dirait de
prendre l'obésité on a beaucoup plus
d'informations que ce qu'on avait avant
mais ça pose des problèmes de
surinformation le tri dans les
informations on est débordé par ça on a
beaucoup plus d'offres de loisirs mais
finalement au cimic j'ai pas le temps de
tout faire donc donc oui ça va être les
vous vous dites en fait possible on a
été tellement habitués à gérer le manque
la pénurie et donc on sait on sait mieux
gérer la pénurie que je dirais
l'abondant exactement et c'est pas
facile de gérer l'abondance arrêté c'est
pas du tout facile ça ça on se dit mais
ce serait pourquoi est-ce qu'on a des
problèmes en fait c'est très compliqué
de gérer l'abondance on a été élevé
pendant des millénaires à la rareté est
là l'abondance c'est pas si simple en
fait alors quel temps fera beau vous
votre explication comment se fait-il que
je me sens plus pauvres je prends moi
d'abord on se sent plus pauvres qu'avant
en dépit du fait que quand on va au
supermarché tout est moins cher qu'avant
la tension quand tout est moins cher
mais ça on sera tous d'accord un c'est
que et les commandites la valeur de
chaque marchandise on pouvoir d'achat
ouais c'est pourtant le temps de travail
qu'il faut pour acheter saab et c'est
par contre le prix du démantèlement chez
nous voilà bien voilà d'où le titre de
l'émission les prix montent est ce que
le pouvoir d'achat ne pourra plus
assumer pour autant ce qu' il ya une
question importante quel rapport au
travail c'est à dire il ya quelque chose
qui n'existait pas durant les trente
glorieuses où pouvoir d'achat était
beaucoup plus faible être un angle est
d'accord là dessus c'était qu'il y avait
quand même le plein au point avec cette
perspective de progrès social pour tous
associés au plein emploi aujourd'hui et
il faut savoir que en 1970 à la fin des
trente glorieuses 1 il ya deux fois plus
de pauvres qu'aujourd'hui
dans votre sens et quand on est pauvre
au seuil de 50% du revenu médian c'est
comme ça qu'on calcule enfin au calcul
est traditionnellement le taux de
pauvreté donc elle avait deux est pauvre
on mears 110 et sert niveau de vie
beaucoup plus faible qu'aujourd'hui
puisque encore le niveau de vie a plus
que doublé le pauvre allait très bien
revenu il y avait deux fois plus les
pauvres soixante dix c'était les
retraités c'étaient les retraités la
figure du pauvre 70 c'était le vieillard
indigents la porte de l'hospice parce
que le système de retraites était pas
monter en puissance jusqu'à ce jusqu'à
retirer force 71 puis 82 l'arrivée de la
gauche tout à fait vous avez raison la
loi boulin et 82 très bien aujourd'hui
grâce à notre merveilleux système de
protection sociale que d'aucuns
voudraient détricoter et bien le taux de
pauvreté au seuil de 50% chez les
retraités des à 3% 4% l'important c'est
qu'on a fait on a réussi à faire
disparaître
on a transformé le risque vieillesse en
un véritable droit au bonheur c'est pas
beau ça nous devrons d'être fiers vous
avez raison d'arrêter de se mettre dans
la complainte pas mal vous avez raison
il ya des choses qui marchent on devra
les pierres par contre là où ça va pas
là où il ya de la souffrance c'est tous
les gens qui sont en âge de travailler
et leurs enfants parce que les retraités
mais ils se dirigeront plus revanchard
donc tous ceux qui sont en âge de
travailler donc là c'est le poids du
chômage du sous-emploi et là vous me
dire mais il ya les allocations chômage
et les minima sociaux oui c'est vrai
qu'ils permettent
2-2 pas tomber plus bas que terre
d'accord enfin vous ai bien compris ça
va quand même ça ça vole pas très bon
quand même en termes de revenus et le
problème il ya un problème de dignité en
plus parce qu'elle les études très
importante de sociologues qui montrent
que quand vous donnez 100 euros à
quelqu'un qui travaille à temps partiel
par exemple quand vous donnez 100 euros
des lampes us par exemple sous la forme
de la prime d'activité et quand vous
donnez 100 euros sous forme de salaire
et bien c'est pas du tout la même chose
100 euros de salaire ça veut dire que je
vaux plus ça veut dire que mon travail
l'opus je vaux plus grâce à mon travail
100 euros de prime d'activité on a le
sentiment de recevoir du net qui est
bienvenu bien entre vous mais ce que je
veux dire mais il ya quelque chose qui
est d'or tu peux être assimilé à l'ordre
de la charité les gens ont envie de
vivre dignement de leur travail et le
problème qu'on a autre le chômage
tous les 1er 2 corvée presque dire
qu'ils sont si mal payés un ticket dont
on a vu avec le comines à quel point ils
sont précieux je pense que la souffrance
elle vient d'abord et avant tout de la
le sentiment que on peut pas travailler
parce qu'il ya du chômage et du
sous-emploi alors qu'il ya plein de
besoins satisfaits ce qui est quand même
aberrant et puis ceux qui travaillent là
parfois sont précarisées trappes sont
obligés de travailler à temps partiel et
voilà donc sont pas reconnus et
s'agirait ça ajoute énormément la
souffrance
c'est l'une des crises que je décris
dans le livre assez de la troisième
crise que j'ai cru qu'ils allaient crise
du travail et que j'appelle la crise de
l'homme exactement pour les raisons que
vous décrivez l'un des paradoxes
incroyable de cette abondance c'est que
quelque part tous les prix ont baissé
mais le prix du travail a baissé aussi
c'est à dire que quelque part l'économie
de moins en moins aptes à rémunérer le
travail parce que la machine à s'est
beaucoup développée on est finalement
l'économie a moins besoin du travail
humain c'est ça c'est l'arrêté choses et
les gens ce qu'ils vivent
je suis industries industries de
formation mais vous voyez des usines qui
produisent beaucoup plus et qu'ils
réduisent leurs effectifs parce que
quelque part la productivité augmente de
plus en plus en réalité le fait qu'on
ait besoin de travailler moins pour
acheter la contra positif c'est que
effectivement votre travail vous avez
d'abord le temps de travail diminue
considérablement depuis depuis 200 ans
quand même et même depuis 1910 on
travaille de moins en moins au long de
la vie d'une part parce qu'effectivement
il ya eu 7 sept merveilles de retraite
qui nous prend de plus en plus de place
et donc en fait on travaille vous
travaillez vous pourriez aller jusqu'à
70% de vous deviez veiller dans l'est au
début du deuxième siècle travail et la
moyenne était autour des 40 50 %
aujourd'hui la moyenne du temps compass
audi rs autour d'une vie c'est autour de
12% desnos la mi temps 10 % de notre
existence carences de notre temps
éveillé pendant la séance hier qu'en
gros vous avez à peu près la moitié de
votre existence qui en gros les vingt
premières années et les 30 derniers on
vous travaillez pas moi en tout cas vous
travaillez pas pour une forme rémunéré
puisque je voudrais vraiment faire la
séparation entre le travail rémunéré le
travail non rémunéré quand vous garder
les enfants quand vous occupez chez vous
c'est une forme de travail mais qui
n'est pas rémunéré
travail associatif travail associatif
bénévolat etc et en fait on passe plus
de temps d'ailleurs à travailler de
façon gratuite que de façon aux grands
dj de façon amicale et donc en fait le
travail rémunéré c'est une quarantaine
d'années où vous travaillez à peu près
28 % de votants éveillé puisque vous
avez il amendé journée où il n'y a pas
ou ne peuvent pas que travailler vous
avez des week-ends la fin des vacances
donc donc en fait on travaille de moins
en moins et le temps de travailler mieux
et ça c'est un vrai c'est un vrai
problème voilà c'est c'est en fait ce
que prévoyait kainz dans les années 1930
il fait une conférence pour les
merveilleuses à madrid et qui s'appelle
que vous connaissez très bien
en tout cas perspectives économiques
pour mes petits-enfants et il annonce
que dans son temps donc on y est presque
on est en 2030 dans son temps le temps
de travail aura aura 10 millions
finalement on aura on aura les appelle
les progrès composé fabrique les
l'économie aura 12 aura tellement fait
progresser qu'on aura besoin de beaucoup
moins travaillée et le thème du livre
que je propose c'est qu'effectivement on
y est et y prédit que ce sera très
difficile et il prédit aussi qu'on
pourra se satisfaire tous nos besoins
prévu qu'on aura de quoi satisfaire nos
besoins l'économie sera capable de
satisfaire ses nombreuses whisky le cas
aujourd'hui gernez à une abondance
incroyable par rapport à ça il est maire
au niveau mondial ce dont les gens ne se
rendent pas compte on produit en
nourriture plus qu'il ne faut pour même
si c'est mal répartie plus qu'il ne faut
pour nourrir convenablement toute la
plaine l'espérance de vie en afghanistan
annoncent aujourd'hui de 15 ans plus
élevée que celle qu'elle était en france
ou en angleterre à l'époque de keynes en
afghanistan voilà donc donc donc
effectivement on a on a aujourd'hui un
progrès absolument considérable est ce
que kane ce disque est absolument
merveilleux c'est ça va être très
difficile parce que nous avons été
habitués à souffrir et pas et nous ne
savons pas jouer on ne vend pas profiter
de ça et il lui prédit ces apps ce texte
est absolument exceptionnel vraiment et
et c'est un texte très court qu'il fait
quelques pages mais qui ils dit vraiment
ils sont complètement à la fois cette
logique d'amour non ce qui est en train
d'exploser complètement d'arrivée avec
avait avec les pros vécu pour lui y voit
qu'avec cannabis arrive à prédire
l'avenir oui mais aimer absolument et et
donc il prédit aussi la difficulté qu'on
va avoir à maîtriser cette avance et
c'est ça qui est très difficile aux est
l'une des difficultés qu'on a c'est
qu'effectivement notre travail la force
de travail qu'on peut fournir et de
moins en moins valorisées par le marché
par l'économie de marché ça c'est vrai
que c'est un sujet qui est un sujet
humain essentiel parce qu'on a besoin
effectivement d'avoir une perspective de
reconnaissance et les pistes de
réflexion autour de ça c'est
effectivement comment ce que vous vous
laury's et le travail qui n aurait
minoré comment est ce que vous arrivez à
voir peut-être un travail qui est pas
rémunéré une rémunération qui est pas
lié au travail et les deux se sépare en
réalité de plus en plus vous avez de
plus en plus de périodes vous avez une
rémunération son travail comme
effectivement la retraite et c'est très
bien vous avez des périodes où vous
travaillez sans être minorée et c'est
cette séparation est en train de se
faire de plus en plus en réalité ce
serait quoi aimer que demi et
républicaine puisque votre livre ne
sortira que que dans quelques jours je
n'es donc pas pus le coup de l'irc
estrabaud
mais d'abord c'est de dire qu'on vit pas
dans les sociétés d'abondance on général
moi je suis pas d'accord avec ce
diagnostic bien sûr mais à blassac voilà
je pense qu on est dans les eaux néo
dans des sociétés où il ya du progrès
par rapport à hier très bien voilà mais
enfin il faut pas sous-estimer à
l'échelle mondiale et même en france
vous avez un institut qui s'appelle le
crédoc qui fait des études sur le la
consommation à des études très précises
bon qui montre à quel point il faut pas
même quand même pas sous-estimer le mal
logement la nourriture saine les loisirs
ou qu'elle renonce encore beaucoup trop
de bois là donc je pense qu'il ya
vraiment pas mal de besoins satisfaits
alors pour eux pourront écrire sur
l'économie républicaine le le sentiment
que j'ai simulé c'est qu'on fait il ya
un socle d'accord politique très fort
sur le suffrage leers il a raison pour
laquelle on souffre l'économie échappe à
cause du néolibéralisme d'accord à cause
de ce capitalisme néolibéral qui au
service des intérêts d'une infime
minorité très bien comment y répondre et
le point de vue c'est de rassembler ces
deux continents donc quand j'ai
rassemblé ça veut dire ça veut pas dire
les mais les superposer mais les faire
dialoguer économie et république quand
vous allez sur un moteur de recherche
met une tannée fait le soir tapez
économie républicaine et bien en fait
c'est étonnant il n'y a pas de travaux
sur le sujet il ya des travaux
d'historiens sur l'école mis sous la
révolution française sous la troisième
république très bien mais l'idée de
rapprocher ces deux continents nos
valeurs républicaines démocratiques peu
importe les termes qu'on utilise à ce
niveau et l'économie ce n'est jamais
fait évidemment on voit de vue c'est de
dire que pour remettre l'économie à
l'endroit tant qu'elles fonctionnent
mieux pour qu'elles satisfassent mieux
les besoins sociaux il faut partir de la
république avec deux volets il ya deux
volets dans la république la fais courte
ya un volet libéral
ya vrai libéral dans la démocratie pour
vivre en démocratie on république faut
la liberté de penser de s'associer de se
réunir c'est très bien c'est fondamental
ni un volet qui n'est pas libéral c'est
le volet proprement républicain
justement c'est l'idée que pour vivre
république ya aussi mahomet mais les
êtres humains sur un pied d'égalité ne
compte que pour 1 on élit des
représentants qui font la loi qui
s'applique à tous y compris à ceux qui
ne sont pas d'accord voilà y compris
parce que parce que il ya besoin de
porter l'intérêt général de la société
le volet proprement républicain c'est le
volet c'est le volet de l'état il ya
besoin d'état et a pour l'économie c'est
pareil et en fait la raison pour
laquelle nous souffrons déjà c'est que
nous ne saisissons mal à quel point dès
aujourd'hui en fait nos économies elles
sont déjà en partie républicaine serbie
est un pôle où il ya un bon public est
très importante on appréhende très très
mal un cercle
ou dit toujours la comparaison en termes
d'indicateurs ne serait-ce qu'en dépit
d'indicateurs qu'on utilise quel
indicateur des dépenses publiques est
totalement farfelu il n'est pas fort
humainement faire ce qu'on lui fait dire
est complètement complètement stupide 1
56% du pib 62 plan taux de dépense
unique avec le avec le co vide en 2020
ça signifie absolument pas ce que la
plupart des gens en tête que on prélève
62% sur les gens du prime et qui
seraient les simples productifs pour
faire font payer les fonctionnaires
improductifs tout ça c'est complètement
du début jusqu'à la fin de la phrase est
fausse d'accord bon les fonctionnaires
augmente le pib 6 vertus du pib dans
tous les pays du monde on considère que
les gens qui travaillent paient dans les
associations s'y sont payés mais qu'on
remet pas le bénévolat et à mon avis ce
juste ne pas mettre le bénévolat soit
dit en passant il augmente le pib bons
mets donc voila et les trois quarts de
la dépense publique en fait ça certains
payer les fonctionnaires ça sert à payer
des prestations sociales
salimo que le revenu des ménages plein
de subventions aux entreprises
s'alimentent le privé oui on vit déjà
dans d économie mixte mais on a su ou
pas comme tel nous n'assumons pas comme
tel est mon point de vue c'est de dire
qu' il faut comme neri faut il faut il
faut partir de là pour approfondir ce
projet hors de d'économie républicaine
qui existe déjà en partie donc il ya
déjà il ya déjà là en quelque sorte de
l'émancipation voilà mais qu'il faut
mieux saisir mieux appréhender
de façon à pouvoir un pouvoir décider un
avenir radieux alors t'es pas
l'abondance
pourquoi pas
non on est évidemment qu'on n'est pas
dans l'abondance aujourd'hui que c'est
un progrès les dessine c'est une
dynamique on sait quelque chose vers
lequel on doit continuer à aller sur le
sur ce que vous disiez sur l' équilibre
entre liberté et
rôles de la redistribution des tables
bien sûr après tout la question est où
est ce qu'on met le curseur aujourd'hui
on est on est on peut argumenter le fait
qu'en france effectivement on n'a qu'à
un état qui est déjà extrêmement
redistributif extrêmement présent le 56%
que vous citiez ça doit être le plus
tout le plus élevé ou le deuxième plus
élevé peut-être parce qu'il faut être
devant le danemark malgré tout donc on
doit être le taux le plus élevé donc
donc ça reste un état qui est
aujourd'hui extrêmement redistributif
toute la question c'est de savoir où est
ce qu'on met le bon équilibre entre la
production de richesse qui effectivement
liée à la liberté au marché et sa
redistribution aujourd'hui très
clairement enfin en tout cas c'est mon
avis mais on a et on a plutôt régressé
en termes de capacité a produit en
redistribue beaucoup il faut pas oublier
de produire également la richesse c'est
la richesse là ça fait aussi part à
marché qui fonctionne mieux je pense pas
que ce soit d'ailleurs un sujet de
2 forcément de plus ou moins d'état mais
je pense que c'est un sujet de mieux
d'état dire quelque chose un état qui
soit plus enfin un droit vous parlez de
la loi et c'est évidemment absolument
essentiel et je dire personne n'est plus
attaché à la loi que libéraux même si
l'on qui sont justement qui met la loi
vraiment au centre du contrat social que
je parle du numérique plus classique
mais aujourd'hui on est on est sur un
sur un jury enfin
une complexité de la loi qui s'est en
fait empilés pendant des décennies et
des décennies qui devient complètement
ingérable pour les pour les entreprises
mais aussi pour les particuliers donc on
a plutôt un travail pour moi de
simplification absolument fondamental
est énorme de notre corpus législatif et
un travail autour de comment faire non
pas moins d'état mais mieux d'état mais
en ce qui concerne la bande horse
évidemment qu'on n'est pas dans une
société de l'abondance objectivement
mais si on compare à ce qu'on a connu il
ya trente ans il ya 40 ans il ya 50 ans
il ya cent ans on est dans une société
de l'abondance bien sûr et on est que
woods eut quiconque a vécu en 1970 si
aujourd'hui il peut ce ballet il peut
écouter toute la musique qui veut
regarder toutes les télévisions qu'il
veut et c'est là il est dans l'abondance
toutes les caractéristiques de notre
société aujourd'hui on était des utopies
dans le passé ça quand on au niveau et
parfois je vois là je milite pour des
choses pour des dispositifs comme le
revenu universel comme le dividende ne
l'était ac sera donc doser choses qui
sont qui paraissent des utopies quand on
me dit c'est une étape et jeudi luc tess
une bonne nouvelle parce que toutes les
utopies du passé l'éducation gratuite je
parle même pas du tout la ligne est là
mais l'éducation gratuite le question
chômage la retraite ça c'est tout ça
c'est des utopies on vit dans une utopie
ambulante merci tous les deux d'avoir
participé à ce débat merci de nous avoir
suivis et rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]